aujourd'hui sur cette science les chats
prennent le pouvoir
bonjour et bienvenue pour cette audience
aujourd'hui consacré à l'évolution de
nos amis à quatre pattes les chats d'où
viennent les chats c'est bien connu les
chats aiment le lait donc ils doivent
venir de la voie lactée mais c'est
incroyable ça 15 secondes de vidéo
étaient déjà en train de dire n'importe
quoi
les chats sont des mammifères de la
famille des félidés plus couramment
appelée rif félins les fellahs entérite
et de leurs ancêtres communs de la
capacité de rétracter leurs griffes ce
que les autres mammifères ne savent pas
faire cette famille serait apparu en
asie il ya 11 millions d'années environ
et ce serait très rapidement diversifié
répandue à travers le monde
les espèces fossiles de félins sont
nombreuses mais aucune égalant
célébrités le mondialement réputé tigre
à dents de sabre nord-américains le
smilodon sa popularité le smilodon la
doit à ses longues canines bien sûr mais
aussi aux comics au cinéma et aux jeux
vidéo mais des châteaux né à dents de
sabre
il y en avait aussi en france il s'agit
de maquis rodius un très proche parent
de smilodon et 2e ce minus qui
n'appartient pas aux faits l'homme et
une autre famille de felhi forme nommée
nîmes ravi d donc pour résumer si
macairo ducey smilodon sont des fellahs
alors est ce milieu est un hymne ravages
et l'entrée en forme aujourd'hui
n'est-ce pas bref là il ose se ressemble
mais ils ne sont pas proches parents ça
veut donc dire que les dents de sabre
sont apparus deux fois indépendamment
par un phénomène qu'on appelle la
convergence les dents de sabre sont même
tellement convergentes qu'elle existe
aussi chez d'autres animaux comme
certains marsupiaux carnassiers
d'amérique du sud dignement représentée
par ti lagos 1000 us ah oui on a du mal
à envisager en voyant ce gros matou
qu'il est en fait plus proche des
gentils koala ou des mignons petits
kangourous que n'importe quelle fin
et si avoir des dents de sabre est aussi
répandue c'est que ça doit être bien
pratique mais pourquoi ça c'est la
grande question tu sais que j'adore te
prendre pour un idiot d'habitude mais il
me semble quand même assez évident que
ça devait pas
avira tricoter une danse avec sa soeur
la cua a par mordre belles théories
regardons-y d'un peu plus près regarde
le crâne de smilodon même avec la gueule
ouverte
il ne pouvait rien faire glisser entre
ses crocs et encore moins mordre à moins
qu'il ait pu ouvrir la bouche d'une
façon assez dramatique
ce qui donnerait tout de même un
résultat assez improbable tu m'accordera
mais pas impossible si on regarde dans
la nature actuelle les hippopotames par
exemple et quelques autres mammifères
sont capables de réguler ancrant certes
mais c'est presque toujours pour
impressionner des rivaux sexuelle ou
faire de l'esbrouffe sait jamais pour
mordre
c'est vrai que même s'il pouvait
techniquement mort ça veut pas dire
qu'ils aient et oui d'autant qu'il
aurait dangereusement risques et
l'intégrité de ses crocs en tentant de
maintenir sa prise sur une proie en
train de se débattre
et cela pose de vrais soucis pour les
reconstitutions dans le reportage de la
bbc sur la terre des monstres disparu la
scène de mise à mort du gibier illustre
bien le problème
les smilodon s'y mettent à plusieurs
pour tenir la proie afin que l'un
d'entre eux puisse lui asséner le coup
fatal sans risque pour ces gentils que
nate a un comportement pour le moins
inédit cette scène illustre aussi très
bien le problème qui vit avec la mort
cieux chez les dents de sabre en
l'illustrant pas justement en effet les
réalisateurs ont visiblement préféré
éluder la question de la morsure en
choisissant de ne pas la montrer
national geographic quant à eux ont
choisi de mettre les pieds dans le plat
et au moment de mordre up les dents de
smilodon se redresse et font saillie en
dehors de la bouche on revoit cette
autre action au ralenti très cher ami
donc voilà je n'ai aucune dent contre la
théorie de larmes terrible mais elle a
du plomb dans l aile qu'est ce que tu
proposes de nous pencher sur le principe
d' actualise mme voyance il existe
aujourd'hui des animaux à dents de sabre
les félins d'aujourd'hui n'ont pas de
tente sabres à les félins certes non
mais certains ruminants oui comme le
porte muscles ou encore le cep et bien
sûr les morts et atteint finalement il
n'est pas carnivore qui mangent de
l'herbe et du poisson rome et oublier un
peu le régime alimentaire de seconde
chez ces espèces là les mâles porte des
canines hypertrophié qui leur servent à
se battre entre eux et aussi à séduire
les femelles
je vois pas comment ça pourrait séduire
une semaine des canines de vampires de
cette taille
bah quoi tu ne t'es jamais laissé
séduire par
beau vampire dit pas n'importe quoi et
continue ce qu'il y à de séduisants pour
une femelle c'est que ces organes
hypertrophié et inutiles sont une sorte
d'indicateur de santé un mal qui
parvient à se nourrir correctement et à
survivre malgré cette tare doit être un
chasseur hors pair un tacticien de génie
un prédateur redoutable et respecté
comment comment je vais te l'enlever et
soit deux compacts chapiteau qu'on sait
exactement comment boîtes de nuit quand
un garçon dense toute la nuit comme un
dieu
il semble être un bien meilleur coût que
le geek du coin donc pour résumer grandi
dans égale gros potentiel pour l'avenir
oui tellement que des dents de sabre il
y en a eu partout chez les reptiles
mamma mia par exemple chez le petit
insectivore adams havre en option et
même chez des animaux qui n'étaient pas
carnivores da silva terium qui devait
vaguement ressembler à un minot séance
toute ressemblance serait pure
coïncidence et hôpitaux mais rixe dont
la fin du crâne à cette méfiance n'avait
d'égal que sa docilité de petits
ruminants
en fait en y réfléchissant bien les
défenses d'éléphants de sangliers et de
narval sondés d'en modifier qui ont
évolué selon le même principe
même si elles ne sont pas tout à fait en
dents de sabre il fit kwalik le hic
comment un pays qu il ya toujours un hic
le milieu pas de bombe à lui que c'est
que si les dents de sabre servait
vraiment à la parade nuptiale
alors il n'y a que les mâles qui aurait
dû en avoir comme c'est le cas chez les
petits ruminants actuelle et je parie
que les semis le dos les garçons et les
filles étaient aussi bien pourvues de ce
point de vue pour autant qu'on sache je
dois bien admettre que oui
donc retour à la case départ la boucle
est bouclée bon ben faudrait voir à pas
trop s'éloigner du sujet mais revenons à
nos châteaux que nos amis les chiens les
chats ont été domestiqués à partir d'une
espèce sauvage le loup canis lupus pour
les chiens et de chats sauvages felis
silvestris pour les chats par conséquent
votre chat c'est un fait lisse et votre
chien c'est un lupus
contrairement à ce que l'on prend
souvent les chaînes ont pas été
domestiqués en egypte car les plus
anciennes traces archéologiques
deux chalets sont vieilles que de trois
mille six cents ans par contre on a
retrouvé des preuves archéologiques de
la domestication des chats remontant à
9000 ans environ à chypre et en israël
et on pense donc que les chats auraient
été domestiqués dans cette région là où
d'ailleurs sonné l'agriculture ainsi que
les premières grandes agglomérations
telles que jéricho les chats auraient
donc été domestiqué il ya dix mille ans
en tant que bon nombre d'animaux de
basse cour
tandis qu on a des indices de la
domestication du chien remontant à plus
de 30 millions pourquoi une telle
différence
est ce que ce serait un complot des
chiens contre licha non je ne crois pas
je crois que c'est tout simplement parce
que les chats n'ont aucun intérêt
et bah quoi tu vas pas dire le contraire
les chats n'apportent aucun bénéfice
évident au foyer qui les accueillent
il le faut comme bidon c est une gloire
de rien de leur journée ils dépensent
leurs premiers au baby foot
ils passent leur temps à fumer des
pétards et à grimper au plafond
la question est dans ce cas pourquoi les
oreilles tant domestiques et l'excusent
des chats chassant les souris est bien
mignonne mais faut pas pousser
les chiens sont pas plus maladroit que
les chats pour chasser les souris plus
léché yz à la chasse il a été montré que
grâce à eux les chasser un bushmen sont
capables de rapporter jusqu'à 80% de
gibier en plus que quand ils chassent
son chien la domestication du chien par
homo sapiens ne serait d'ailleurs pas
tout à fait étrangère à l' avantage
décisif qu'il a pris sur l'homme de
néandertal qui lui n'avait pas d'animaux
domestiques pour l'aider à chasser les
chats eux n'ont fait qu'apporter de
nouvelles maladies comme la très
redoutée toxoplasmose et leurs fameux
allergies malgré ça les chats ont su se
faire accepter auprès de nous et se
faire entretenir aux frais de la
princesse est fait non mais attends je
crois que j'ai compris ça y est tout est
clair en fait ce sont les chars qui nous
ont domestiqué
tout s'explique
6 millions c'est le ronronnement nous
attendrissent autant mais c'est parce
que c'est le meilleur moyen pour eux
d'obtenir ce qu'ils veulent de nous sans
le ronron et leur charme le filin
l'humanité se rendra vite compte de la
supercherie
ceci était un message de prévention du
ccc le comité contre les chats bref
l'évolution des chats nous montre que la
domestication n'est pas un phénomène à
sens unique mais bien une relation dont
l'influencé réciproque entre l'homme et
son compagnon
les jeunes ne sont pas indispensables on
les aime bien quand même
et tant qu'ils sauront se faire aimer
notre évolution est la leur continueront
d'avancer de concert pour en savoir plus
sur ces sujets nous vous conseillons les
nombreux liens qui sont dans la
description et notamment les articles
consacrés à la domestication sur le blog
francophone
ce trust of ancient tennis merci à tous